[Music]
you did this to me
lottie yanked her arm from the man's
grip scowling
hands off hun she said flicking her
cigarette butt at his shoes
you want something you make an
appointment like everyone else
the man made no further attempt to touch
her but simply stood there with his
shoulders slumped
in a damp overcoat that was too big for
him
look at me he said almost too quietly
for lottie to hear
she obliged and looked at him he wasn't
familiar but then she saw a lot of men
and couldn't be expected to remember
every single one
besides that he had a baseball cap
tugged down over his eyes
and the collar of his coat pulled up
over his chin
it was a warm night he must be
sweltering
lottie glanced up and down the street
lights were burning in most of the
apartment windows around her
but no one appeared to be outside she
considered the man before her
you can come up if you want she said
reaching into her purse for her keys
but no funny stuff i've got a gun she
had two of them actually
a black 38 revolver under the bed
upstairs and the silver 22 she always
carried in her handbag
a girl could never be too careful the
man shuffled after her as she made her
way up to the third floor of her
apartment building
he didn't say anything but the labored
rasps of his breathing made lottie
suspect that he was ill
or at least drastically out of shape she
flicked on all the lights as soon as she
opened the door
the apartment was small but considerably
less dreary than some of the other
places she lived
at least it was clean with no cracks in
the ceiling or unidentifiable stains on
the carpet
sit on the couch over there she
commanded pointing
she kept her purse close to her side the
weight of the 22 reassuring
i'll make us some coffee from the bright
little kitchenette she could watch the
man
as he settled himself delicately amid
the scattered cushions
he kept his head lowered so that she
couldn't get a decent glimpse of his
face
but this only made her more determined
she thought she could see part of an ear
and it looked red and strangely
misshapen
his hands were covered with leather
gloves which she hadn't noticed before
so have we met she asked as the coffee
began to percolate
the man gave a short laugh that sounded
like a rusty hinge
yeah we sure did he tapped his gloved
fingers on his knee
keeping his head down staring intently
into his lap
we sure did lottie wondered if this was
all an act
if the man was just some psycho trolling
for easy victims
he might even have a weapon under that
heavy coat she
supposed it had been stupid of her to
invite him up but risk of course
was a built-in component of her
profession the day she found herself
truly afraid of any man
was the day she'd have to hang it all up
just in case though she quickly snatched
the 22 from her purse and stuffed it in
the waistband of her skirt in the back
then she pulled her blouse down over it
and carried the mugs over to the sofa
the man accepted his coffee without
comment leaning forward on the couch
with the cup clasp between his hands
lottie sat in the recliner opposite
where she'd have a clear shot at him if
he sprang
what's on your mind he flicked his gaze
up toward her without moving his head
his eyes were shadowed pools i was here
two weeks ago
he said his voice low and rattling with
phlegm
you wore the school girl outfit and hit
me with a wooden paddle
i told you my name was shawn do you
remember
lottie cast her mind back she thought
she could just recall that appointment
early evening the guy good looking but
nothing special
with an eagerness that suggested a
novice lottie had pegged him as a frat
boy type
although he'd mentioned that he was
married with a baby son
she newly appraised the man sitting
before her having a hard time
reconciling his image with her memory of
the golden boy from before
she didn't say this though yes i think i
remember you
i look a little different now don't i
moving slowly as though he was a very
old man
shawn reached up and dragged the
baseball cap from his head
lottie gasped then coughed to cover it
not wanting to provoke him
beneath his hat shawn had gone
completely bald his head a lumpy mass of
red sores
his face was likewise patched with welts
and swellings and various shades of
crimson and purple
the flesh and the valleys between the
welts sloughing off like reptile skin
after he'd given her a good look he put
the hat back on
i won't show you the rest he said his
eyes seeming to twinkle in the darkness
beneath the brim
but i'm sure you can imagine i'm sure
lottie set her coffee cup on the floor
at her feet no longer wanting it
she combed her fingers through her curly
red hair and you're showing me this
because
i told you you did it how could i have
she began but he waved his hand to
silence her
he sipped from his mug and lottie's
stomach churned
she'd have to throw that cup away now no
telling what germs he was spreading i
haven't been with anyone except my wife
and you sean explained calmly the
doctors say it's probably sexually
transmitted
they don't know exactly what it is but
they do know that much
that and the fact that it's terminal now
wait a minute i've been checked out i
haven't got anything
maybe you got it some other way lottie
found herself pressing her body against
the back of her chair
as if to get as far away from him as
possible anyway
she said even if i did give it to you
what can i do about it now
what do you want from me he stared at
her with his black
eyes lottie wished she could turn off
the overhead light
it bathed him in a sickly yellow glow
making his ruined skin appear a
disturbing greenish orange
i just wanted you to know i guess he
said and then he coughed
long and loudly sounding as though he
was preparing to bring up a lung
when he had recovered he took another
slug of his coffee
trying to do my duty for mankind you
know he laughed which brought on another
fit of coughing
lottie's heart was thumping please don't
let him die right here on my sofa
she silently prayed shawn produced a
handkerchief from the pocket of his coat
and spat into
it then wiped it as runny eyes sorry
he said i'm afraid i'm not very good
company these days
lottie reached around behind her
surreptitiously feeling for the gun
surely he couldn't fake that cough
surely he was too sick to do too much
damage
well you've told me now she said
managing to keep her voice even
i think you should leave shawn leaned
back against the cushions
scratching at his face with his leather
gloves tiny flakes of skin drifted down
into his lap
hey i just got here he said he reached
into his pocket and lady almost screamed
but all he produced was a pack of
cigarettes he held the pack out to her
but she shook her head
he pulled one out of the pack with his
lips then felt around in his coat for a
lighter
i quit smoking years ago he said
lighting up and taking a long drag
but with all this going on you know the
dying thing
he shrugged what the hell i figure
lottie's hand shook on the gunbutt was
she really gonna have to shoot him
and would it matter that much judging by
the look of him he wouldn't last the
week
i'm really sorry sean even as she said
the words she knew she didn't really
mean them
i wish there was something i could do
for you well
now that you mention it there might be
sean watched her through blue tendrils
of smoke
after a long moment he went for his
pocket very slowly and deliberately this
time
his eyes never leaving her face this is
it
he's going to kill me lottie thought and
with no more conscious decision on her
part
she whipped the 22 out from behind her
back and squeezed the trigger
four times the knights were much colder
here
but lottie was used to it by now the
tights she wore were heavy but sheer
her coat short but bulky she leaned
against a frigid lamppost
her breath coming out in white puffs it
had been three months since shawn
she had left the apartment that night
with nothing but her purse and the
clothes on her back
shawn's reptilian body splayed across
the old white futon
he hadn't even had any cash on him
a car crept past and lottie swung her
hips
leaned forward to peer into the window
but then the engine roared and the car
squealed off
she made an obscene gesture at the
retreating taillights then resumed her
place at the lamppost
street hooking was really the pits
compared to the relative comfort and
safety of her previous gig
running her own online escort service
made her feel like an entrepreneur
now she was just a common horror and was
treated accordingly
the money wasn't bad but the clientele
were certainly a step or two down from
what she was used to
still though she had her secret weapon
she smiled to herself
thinking of poor sean in his hideous
malady he'd done her a favor in a way
showing her the devastation she carried
inside her
since coming to this new city she
reckoned she had probably condemned a
couple of hundred men perhaps more
some of them had come back to see her
afterwards and some hadn't
maybe some hadn't realized where their
death sentence had come from
lottie had felt a pang of conscience
when she'd heard through the grapevine
that the men were passing the disease
onto their wives and mistresses
but it had been only fleeting no one was
blameless
after all and even though she felt the
most contempt for the men who visited
her
she also learned to hate the women who
allowed them to stray so far from their
vows of fidelity
she taken to calling herself typhoid
lottie if only in her mind
she hadn't been to the hospital herself
besides the fact that she was still
wanted for murder
and needed to keep a low profile she had
so far not displayed any symptoms of
illness
and so assumed that she was merely a
carrier in her darkest moments she saw
herself as the last great plague upon
the earth
holy vengeance upon those who sinned the
idea amused her
but also terrified her with its powerful
allure
another car crawled by then sped up she
sighed
it was very cold and there hadn't been
much traffic along the road in hours
even though it wasn't yet two she
decided to call it a night
she pulled her coat tight around herself
and buttoned it up to the neck
when she raised her head the car was
idling there at the curb
she hadn't heard it pull up lottie
stayed where she was
her fingers still lingering around her
throat it was a nice car
a mustang she thought shiny and
obviously new
its color was an odd minty green that
seemed to pulse and change under the
street lights
frosty air chuffed from the tailpipe the
window on the passenger side glided down
and a man leaned across from the
driver's seat hello
he said smiling cold tonight isn't it
yes how very observant of you lottie
thought but she returned his smile
tossing her red curls sure is
he was a young man probably early 30s
lean and handsome
his hair was chestnut and looked as
though it had been cut at an expensive
salon
he was tan and manicured definitely a
cut above the guys lotta usually saw
along this strip
she unbuttoned her coat again slowly
revealing the shimmering black mini
dress beneath
bet it's warm in that car though she
purred strutting closer on her spike
heels
well let's see he pushed the passenger
door open
and watched her as she climbed in beside
him that's better isn't it
lottie had to admit the heater blowing
on her legs did feel lovely
she closed the mustang's door with a
decisive thunk
so what's your pleasure mr k damon k
and you are your worst nightmare lottie
thought with a grin
mary she told him all right then mary
i thought we'd just take a little drive
is that all right
it's your dime damon k lottie settled
back against the leather seat and
watched the city lights rushing past
they had been driving along for nearly
10 minutes before lottie realized that
she didn't recognize any of the scenery
she glanced over at the driver he was
still smiling his mild innocuous smile
i've never seen this part of the city
before she said
the heat was making her feel pleasantly
drowsy
oh well it's like that sometimes isn't
it when you haven't lived in a place
long
it took a minute or two before his words
registered
she looked at him sharply how did you
know i haven't been here long
she gripped the door handle just in case
she had to make a break for it
she should have known this guy was too
swank for her neighborhood he was
probably a cop damon's expression didn't
falter
hey take it easy i just assumed that's
all because i haven't seen you around
here
he turned his head and looked into her
eyes briefly and i'm not a cop
lottie relaxed a little but kept her
hand where it was
staring out the window again she could
see nothing but the hulking black shapes
of buildings
most of them steeped in shadow the few
streetlights she could see were glowing
and odd swirling crimson
suddenly the warmth from the vents was
oppressive and she squirmed in her heavy
jacket
where are we going she said nowhere in
particular
he said i really just wanted to talk
the passenger side mirror lit up and
lottie squinted into it
she thought she could make out a car
behind them following close
it looked flashy with a red paint job
although that might have been the
scarlet haze from the streetlights
part of her was relieved to see another
vehicle but something about it also made
her very uneasy
friend of yours she asked trying to keep
her voice light
it occurred to her that this guy and the
one behind them might be working as a
team
taking her out to some remote location
to do christ knew what
well if it came to that she still had
her gun and if they did manage to rape
her
they would be the ones who would be
sorry yes indeed
damon glanced into the rear view oh
might be he said
then laughed don't look so suspicious of
everything i told you all i wanted to do
was talk
lottie was beginning to get annoyed and
she didn't like that there seemed to be
no other cars on the road except these
two
none of the streets or buildings was
familiar either and the heater was
making her sweat
so talk she snapped damon reached over
and turned down the heater
better he asked yes sorry i like it
really warm
i forget how uncomfortable it is for
other people sometimes
lottie rolled her eyes i'm losing my
patience mr k
either say what you have to say or pay
me my money and let me out
alright alright damon said still
grinning goodness you are all business
aren't you
he looked into the rear view again then
fixed his gaze back on the road
the problem is mary he glanced at her
again
but that isn't really your name is it i
can see the humor though
typhoid mary funny lottie's throat dried
up
who the [ __ ] was this guy did he know
shawn maybe he was a cop after all
he didn't look like one but that didn't
mean anything i don't know what you're
talking about mister
she said trying to keep her voice from
shaking
right right for someone who's all
business you sure are holding up the
proceedings
anyway i know who you are and what
you've done
so let's not play any more games okay
i'm not going to hurt you
but i don't want any more lies that
clear
lottie he wasn't smiling anymore though
he still appeared fairly harmless
lottie stuck her hand into her purse
felt around for the 22.
she didn't pull it out not yet you a
friend of sean's
she asked sean well i don't know him
personally
i know of him though just like i know
about all the other men you've been
sending over to me lately
and a few women too i guess you must
have heard about that
the car behind revved its engine and
damon waved his hand in greeting
i always got my back that guy he said
his smile slowly returning
lottie's hand closed around the gun tell
me what's going on
she said the sky through the windshield
had started to boil with reddish
scutting clouds
thing is lottie said damon navigating
the mustang around a pile of what looked
like burning human bodies
your little escapades have kind of been
encroaching on the duties of others
namely me don't get me wrong i like your
style and everything
but this plague deal is kind of a
one-person job and if you're the person
doing it well
then where does that leave me i ask you
the street ahead of them was nearly
blocked with corpses and damon steered
the car up onto the sidewalk to get
around them
the roads are really a [ __ ] around here
aren't they
lottie closed her eyes the image of the
stacked bodies burned into her mind
there had been so many of them and they
were also white and thin
almost not like human bodies at all am i
dead
she whispered no no nothing like that
your time will come believe me but it
isn't that time yet
then what lottie was still afraid to
open her eyes
a rancid smell had started to creep into
the car through the heater vents
a smell of blood and pus and rotting
flesh a smell of disease
i've told you you're encroaching on my
territory you're making me look bad
i just want you to stop but who are you
lottie thought of the heat of the red
sky that hung over them
it seemed impossible are you the devil
she said
she thought it would sound stupid when
she said it out loud but was horrified
to find that it didn't
devil damon laughed no not me
he jerked his thumb toward the car
behind them that's the devil
in the car back there the big boss i'm
flattered though
the mustang thumped over something big
and damon swore
lottie didn't want to know what it was
sorry about that
he said anyway as i was saying you've
heard of the four horsemen i presume
lottie just nodded unable to speak well
you're looking at horsemen number four
death rider of the pale horse or in my
case the mint green mustang
i'm also known as pestilence which
should ring a bell
lottie felt unmoored from her
surroundings as though the heat was
pushing her soul out of her body
this all had to be a dream there was no
other explanation
she opened her eyes and looked around
the landscape was now black
featureless an expanse of blasted soil
with nothing growing out of it
but oddly twisted rocks that made lottie
think of pictures she'd seen of mars
the ground was littered with bones most
of them crushed or disarticulated
some deformed beyond recognition the
car's tires crunched blasphemously over
them
you're crazy she managed to rasp
if it makes you feel better to think
that then go right ahead damon glanced
into his rear view again
the red car was still following closely
behind them matching every bump and
shift in speed
anyway i told you before that i wasn't
going to hurt you that it wasn't your
time to die yet
i mean it won't be if we can come to
some type of agreement about all this
agreement lottie could see through the
windshield the landscape ahead
which seemed to be dissolving into
absolute blackness like that of deepest
space
this was more horrifying to her than any
of the previous visions had been
please let him finish talking before we
get up there she prayed
i'll do whatever you want just take me
back she said
the all-consuming blackness grew closer
well
that was easy wasn't it damon said
cheerfully
i have to tell you though i think you're
just humoring me because you're scared
i can understand that but let me just
explain a few things to you before we
come to any definite conclusions
he slowed the car down slightly and
lottie nearly sobbed with relief
the car behind them slowed down at the
exact same moment
you see lottie i usually keep a pretty
close eye on this pestilence thing
to you humans it must not seem like a
big deal well at least to you humans in
the west
to you it probably doesn't seem like
your species is being gradually eroded
by disease
but i can assure you that it is
happening i just like to take my time
so there's no panic when there's panic
some human who's smarter than most will
come up with a cure that'll wipe out the
diseases i've worked so hard inventing
so like i said slow and steady his smile
was brilliant in the greenish glow from
the instrument panel
but then you come along flying under the
radar so to speak
i know you haven't been to a doctor to
discover the specifics of your little
internal epidemic
but some of your victims have and what
you're carrying inside of you lottie is
like nothing i've ever come up with
and it's like nothing any of us have
ever seen and as far as i could
determine
you're the only carrier of it on earth
lottie sat perfectly still her breath
growing quick and harsh
damon glanced over at her yeah i know
it's a lot to process
and i also know that you didn't really
intend to kill anyone at first
even though sean's case could be argued
against you but after that
well he shrugged you're a murderer many
times over lottie
tisk lottie swallowed
wake up now she thought then closed her
eyes again
when i opened my eyes i will be back at
my apartment and none of this will have
happened
she opened her eyes the darkness was
still ahead of them
damon was still grinning at her and the
dim interior of the mustang
forgive me for rambling he said the crux
of the matter is this
you basically have three choices one you
can agree never to spread the disease to
anyone else
ever as long as you live this may seem
easy but keep in mind that if you choose
this option
i will be watching you every second of
every day
as soon as penis meets vagina you're
dead even if you so much as sneeze in
another person's direction you're dead
and not just dead dead but dead of the
disease that you've given to so many
others
and believe me it isn't pretty lottie
thought of sean with his reptile skin
coming off in rotted flakes
she shuddered two damon continued
my associate in the red car can just
take you right now
no muss no fuss get things over with
right away you know
you'll be dead just the same as option
number one but there'll be no suffering
first
and the devil despite his reputation can
be relatively merciful with those he
likes
and he does like you lottie as if in
reply the
red car behind them honked its horn
twice in quick succession
damon laughed and three you typhoid
lottie
can become my understudy if i may say so
you certainly have a knack for the job
i can't offer much in the way of
benefits but you'd get to live forever
albeit with me
and not in a particularly pleasant
neighborhood he gestured to the world
outside the window
still no offense but you weren't exactly
living the high life before
lottie had to admit that this was true
these are my only options
she said quietly as it stands yes i'm
afraid so
damon replied but at least you have
options am i right
most people aren't so lucky lottie
twisted her hands in her lap
despite the heat she now felt terribly
cold all the way down to her bones
this is not happening to me she thought
but she knew that it was
and there was no point in pretending
anymore she had to make a decision
or one would be made for her as if he'd
read her mind damon began humming the
jeopardy theme
i'm giving you exactly 60 seconds he
said
lottie's brain reeled well option two
was definitely out
suffering or not she didn't want to go
straight to the devil if she could help
it
and even the first option where she
ostensibly got to go back to her old
life
because she really lived the rest of her
life that way with pestilence always
breathing down her neck waiting for her
to screw up
and wouldn't she just go to hell when
she eventually died anyway
she buried her face in her hands five
seconds
damon sang lottie raised her head and
stared out through the windshield
she supposed she had better get used to
the scenery the thought made her laugh
bitterly
at last she sighed i choose three she
said
almost under her breath she turned to
look at him
he was still handsome supernaturally so
you knew i'd pick that all along didn't
you oh i hoped
i had to admit i was mad at you at first
for horning in on my racket
but hey you seem like someone i could
work with and i suppose even i could use
an extra pair of hands now and then
what with the apocalypse imminent and
all that he grinned
so that's your answer yes
that's my girl the car's headlights
pierced the darkness
and then they were within it
lottie leaned on the lamppost pulling
her short coat tight around herself
it was cold colder than she ever
remembered it
she'd had a few clients come by earlier
but in the last hour there'd been no one
it didn't matter much though the end was
near but there was no rush
slow and steady that was the ticket
she heard the rumble of the engine
before she saw the mint green mustang
roaring up to the curb
pestilence lowered the window his teeth
glowing white from the driver's seat
let's call it an early night what say
typhoid he said in his booming jolly
voice
you've done enough for today and it's
damn freezing out there hop in i'll even
stop and buy some hot chocolate
lottie couldn't help but smile he wasn't
such a bad sort
all things considered she climbed into
the passenger seat
immediately undoing her coat it's
roasting in here pest
tone it down a shade right right i can't
have anything my way anymore
he was grinning as he said it he turned
down the heater
shall we take the scenic route home
lottie pictured the crooked streets
the boiling red skies the growing stacks
of legion-covered corpses
the future of mankind she thought to
herself and laughed
drive on fourth horseman she said
[Music]
it's up here somewhere there's graves
and everything
sally grabbed a handful of upholstery as
the rickety vauxhall careened around
another hairpin curve
she glanced up at thomas who was next to
her on the back seat he was grinning but
even in the darkness she could tell he
was a little nervous
there's all these old headstones
thomas's uncle dai was driving
and sally could see the outline of his
face and blonde spiky hair illuminated
by the green dashboard lights
she still couldn't get used to seeing
the steering wheel on the right side of
the car
i'm not sure how old they are mind dai
was saying as he maneuvered the vehicle
up another narrow mountain road
but there was some outbreak see hundreds
of years ago the black death or
something
when was that thomas looked at sally
since she always seemed to know such
gruesome things
well she said painfully aware of her
nasal american drawl
i think there was more than one big
plague but i'm pretty sure the famous
black death was around the mid-1600s
dye was nodding yeah that sounds about
right wait till you see them
you can't actually read the gravestones
on account of they're so old and all the
writings come off
he turned right at a sign red kevin
goligh and sally felt the car begin to
ascend even higher
in a way she was glad it was dark so she
didn't have to see how high up they were
they had passed no other cars on the
remote mountain roads at this time of
night
the only light came from the sliver of
moon hanging overhead
the street lamps of the villages far
below and the questing headlights of
dye's vauxhall
the road and mountains looked gray and
ghostly in their flat glow
hey die if you can't find them it's no
big deal we could come back when it's
light if you want
thomas's voice still held a trace of a
welsh lilt even though he'd lived in
america for more than 10 years
the family had teased him for talking
like a yank but sally thought he sounded
just the same as when she'd met him
no no they're right round here won't be
a minute i'll find them then i'll pop
you back home
don't want to go home yet do you no of
course not
sally actually did want to go home the
long flight back to orlando took off
tomorrow night
and they hadn't even begun packing but
she liked dye and didn't want to hurt
his feelings
besides it was only a little past nine
not late at all maybe they could even
stop her chips on the way back to
thomas's parents house where they'd been
staying
sally peered out into the darkness she
had no idea where they were now
her sense of direction was rotten anyway
and after the seemingly millions of
twists turns switchbacks and roundabouts
they'd taken
they could have been on neptune for all
she knew in fact she thought they might
as well be
south wales certainly looked like an
alien landscape compared to wide flat
balmy central florida
right along here somewhere dye was
muttering leaning so far forward that
his nose nearly brushed the windscreen
he was a broad and muscular man where
thomas was tall and live
loud and gregarious where thomas was
introspective and reserved
dye had brought them on this adventure
on a whim after driving over to western
monarch for petrol
before embarking on this leg of the tour
hoping to locate the possibly fictitious
black death graves
he'd driven them past a few decrepit old
churches and shown them a pub that was
supposedly haunted by the spirits of
people who had died in accidents on the
road in front
of it sally smiled at the memory die i
was always full of stories
only ten percent of which you could
actually take seriously
well you can't see them from here die
was stopping the car
pulling off the road a little way even
though there was no one else around for
miles
but see that little rise there the
graves are just behind that
sally slid closer to thomas so she could
look out his window
she squinted and in the indirect glow of
the headlights she thought she could see
the suggestion of a low hill
she also saw a slope leading down to a
large lake and a disturbing black edge
like that of a cliff opposite the lake
cool
shame we can't see them in the dark the
relief in thomas tone was obvious
as was his attempt to hide it like i
said we should come back in the day time
maybe on our next visit yeah maybe
dye tapped his fingers on the dash for a
few beats clearly mulling something over
then he gripped the steering wheel in
both hands and turned hard into the
bumpy terrain just off the shoulder of
the road
sally felt the harsh bump as the tires
left the asphalt
i really want you to see him though dai
said it ain't far i think i can make it
sally and thomas exchanged glances the
car shuttered and creaked around them
sounding as though every bolt on it was
being shaken loose
sally tried to keep a smile plastered on
her face but the farther they got from
the safety of the road the more
difficult it was to do
thomas reached across the back seat and
curled his hand over hers
just a bit more dye appeared to be
fighting the wheel
though who was winning was anyone's
guess sally peeked out the window on her
side and saw the tires hovering
perilously close to that craggy black
edge
her heart thumped and skipped in time
with the car's seasick motion
maybe the slope on the side wasn't even
that steep but in the darkness it was
impossible to tell
in the darkness it looked like a sheer
drop sally wondered how close they were
to the other edge
the one that sloped down into the lake
but she didn't dare ask thomas to tell
her
looking out this side was bad enough the
little car hewed and teetered
dye was whistling a jaunty tune as he
drove his apparent lack of concern
only made sally more uneasy he's brought
us up here to kill us and bury us where
no one will find the bodies
she wasn't sure where the thought had
come from but under these circumstances
in this profound silent darkness it
seemed possible even likely
sure dai had always seemed like a sweet
popular guy generous to a fault and a
fountain of hilarious anecdotes but to
be fair she'd only met him a few times
on previous visits
maybe he had a dark side that nobody
knew about wasn't that always happening
on those forensic science shows she
watched
he was such a nice man the neighbors
invariably said we never suspected that
he chopped up babies and walled up the
pieces in his basement rumpus room
she glanced at thomas again and by the
grim set of his jaw she could tell that
he was thinking along similar lines
this only heightened her anxiety since
he presumably knew dye a great deal
better than she did another cautious
peek out the window showed the car
see-sawing toward the abyss for a second
before writing itself in the rocky turf
sally squeezed her eyes shut
wishing she was anywhere else even
eating black pudding in front of
emmerdale
at last the car shuttered to a halt at a
slight angle and dye killed the engine
look fair he said sally opened her eyes
slowly and looked out through the grimy
windscreen
floating there in the circle of white
light from the headlights was a small
cluster of leaning headstones
obviously old some broken in half some
lying like abandoned corpses in the
grass
the sight of them in the cold spotlight
surrounded by darkness and the silent
mountains was undeniably eerie
it was as though they hadn't existed at
all until someone had come along and
shown a light on them
sally felt a tingling up and down her
arms i'll see if i can get a bit closer
die started the car up again and the
vauxhall chugged a few more yards
forward
the graves grew larger in the headlights
and to sally they seemed almost defiant
in their listing disrepair
these forgotten monuments of human
frailty biding their time in these
hidden mountains
rarely seen but ever present sally
shuddered again
and the feeling was not entirely
unpleasant i've never been here at night
before
now dye sounded almost as nervous as she
and thomas had felt earlier
and sally almost laughed out loud she'd
had prosaic concerns about him driving
off a mountain sure
but dye seemed to be afraid of the
graves themselves
you don't believe in ghosts do you die
sally had no desire to cruelly poke fun
but she did feel the need to take her
small petty revenge for what he'd put
them through with his off-road antics
i do i dai said without a hint of his
usual humor
i've seen a few myself up in the
mountains than that frighten the life
out of me they do
he looked back over his shoulder as
though searching for the quickest escape
route
his face was nothing but a silhouette
against the crumbling cemetery spread
out before them
aren't we going to get out and look
sally knew he wanted to leave but she
wasn't finished tormenting him yet
besides he was the one who'd driven them
all the way up here wasn't he
i want to see him up close i don't know
sal you won't be able to see much
it's awful dark sally smiled
come on you're not chicken are you she
stole a glance at thomas who looked
amused but uncertain
stay with me on this she told him
silently if they were going to see the
graves they would all have to go
she didn't trust dye taking off and
leaving her alone on this pitch-black
mountain with no idea how to get back to
the village
don't be like that love dye still seemed
anxious but in the darkness she thought
she could see the twist of a grin on his
face
look we'll pop over there a second but
don't blame me if one of them black
death bastards reaches up out of the
ground and drags you down to hell right
sally grasped the door handle don't
worry i can take care of myself
the three of them trudged through the
tufts of soft grass their breath making
frosty little clouds in the autumn
night's chill
the headlights shone blue white cutting
a slice out of the darkness
guiding their way to the beckoning
stones their six footfalls seemed to be
the only sounds in the universe
the tiny graveyard seemed even sadder
and more eerie as they approached it
the stones that still stood were badly
weathered and the ones that had fallen
looked like nothing but random bits of
broken masonry
with no clue left to reveal their
intended purpose
sally knelt by one reasonably intact
marker lifting the hem of her black
skirt to keep it out of the mud
she couldn't read the name carved in the
stone but there was some fairly legible
writing there
though it was all in welsh a language of
which she understood very little
there was however a clear death date
1832
so the graves were plenty old but not as
ancient as dyad thought
and it was unlikely that the people
buried here had perished in the black
death
unless the disease had taken 200 years
to travel from london to tardigra
so what had killed them the faded
etching on another stone gave her the
answer
they died of cholera she said then
immediately wish she hadn't spoken
her crass american accent seemed a
blasphemous cacophony in this quaint
little enclave of death
aye that's right dye was whispering but
his voice still seemed to carry an echo
over the nearby hills
black death cholera knew it was
something like that he was standing near
the edge of the ragged ring of graves as
if fearful of crossing some imaginary
line in the grass
he shifted his weight from one foot to
the other guess we should be getting
back now
thomas's mother will be wondering where
we've got to
sally had planned on prolonging the
torture a bit longer but suddenly she
too wanted to get as far away from her
as possible
she scoffed at herself she didn't
believe in ghosts and graveyards
normally didn't bother her
but she was starting to agree with dye
this place was hellish creepy at night
even the air seemed heavier hovering
over the graves like a noxious gas
she thought again of how the cemetery
had seemed to float out of the darkness
as soon as the headlights were trained
upon it and she shivered
alright let's go she looked around for
thomas who hadn't spoken a word since
they'd got out of the car
then took his hand and began making her
way back toward the source of the
headlight beam
even the usually garrulous die was
silent on the mercifully short track to
the leaning vox hall
they were all bundled in the car with
the doors tightly closed and locked
before dye said
now let's see if i can get back to the
road in a voice that seemed fairly
confident in its owner's ability to do
just that
sally glanced back at the black edge in
the lake not too thrilled at having to
drive between them again
but now eager to get back on the road
and back down to the valleys
with its close-packed villages and
well-lit pubs she'd had quite enough of
the dark guard rail-less mountains for
one vacation thank you very much
dye swung the car in a huge arc for one
second bringing the graves within a few
yards of the window glass
sally caught sight of a jagged corner a
broken off arch of stone
she didn't know how it was possible but
the graves looked even creepier without
the direct glow of the headlights
shining upon them
the shapes of the stones recalled the
shapes of hunched and broken bodies
and the illegible carvings seemed like
esoteric messages from lost
civilizations
in the dark sally could almost see the
diseased corpses being carried up to
this remote little spot
far from the terrified townsfolk below
she can almost hear the creek of the
cartwheels under their grisly burden
hear the squelch of the spades in the
loamy earth who had been given the task
of bringing the infectious dead to their
hidden resting places
did these unfortunate pallbearers know
they were taking their own lives in
their hands
as they carried their diseased cargo the
lake yawned black on her side of the car
as dye steered back toward the road
the vauxhall was jumping around like a
tin can in a hurricane
and sally wondered if the suspension
would ever be the same again
the road seemed tantalizingly close a
thin black ribbon on the horizon
suddenly the little car bounced hard
lifting her an inch off the seat
dye bumped his head on the ceiling hey
sally began
diet stomped on the gas the vauxhall's
tire spun in the dirt for a moment
before jumping forward with a grinding
roar
sally hung on for dear life she spotted
dye's eyes in the rearview mirror
huge and terrified [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] he
bellowed
he tried to push the gas pedal through
the floor the little car leaped and
banged
then skidded and went airborne for three
heart-stopping seconds
it hit the ground careering die stop it
what's the matter with you
thomas yelled gripping the back of the
driver's seat with knobby white hands
look for [ __ ] sake look die screamed
turning the steering wheel this way and
that
pushing forward with his body as though
doing so would make the car go faster
sally and thomas turned in unison to
look out the back window but the car was
jerking and bumping around so much that
neither of them could focus on anything
sally cast a panicked look at her
husband what the hell had dye seen in
the rear view
don't you see them dye's voice was ready
and desperate
he didn't even seem to be looking
forward toward the road anymore his eyes
were enormous blue circles in the mirror
the vauxhall slid in the grass and
wobbled toward the steep slope leading
down to the lake
sally gritted her teeth to keep from
shrieking we are going to get out of
this
she thought cut it out die she shouted
struggling to be heard of the squealing
tires
what kind of sick joke is this slow down
they're back there they're coming
he was hysterical now babbling himself
hoarse
sally looked over at thomas and saw that
he was plastered against the back seat
his body rigid
his eyes were closed his lips moved
soundlessly cut the [ __ ] die do you want
to get us killed
she knew it was probably no use trying
to reason with him at this point
she slapped him on the arm but he didn't
seem to notice jesus weren't they at the
road yet
she didn't remember it being this far
she tried to reach for the steering
wheel but the car hit another bump and
she was thrown painfully into the back
seat
reeling she whipped around and stared
hard out the back window again
what the hell was dye running from the
cars shook violently but she tried to
focus on the darkness behind them
what was it she couldn't see anything
there was nothing at all
but wait was there something back there
among the graves
she squinted trying to hold herself
steady there was something
several somethings milling around the
stones white
somethings almost like human figures the
car tilted sickeningly but this time
instead of writing itself it fell into
the tilt
and sally screamed as she tumbled first
to the side and then up onto the ceiling
she felt thomas's weight falling against
her and she grabbed for him
unable to tell if he was alive or dead
but holding on to him anyway calling his
name through her screams
the headlights winked crazily casting
flickering movie projector shadows over
the grass the sky the far away hills
the black surface of the lake that was
rushing up to meet them
she began to feel disoriented and faint
a pain shot through her arm and she
dimly realized she'd broken it
but she refused to loosen her grip on
the unsettlingly limp thomas
the only familiar thing for her to hang
on to she didn't know where dye was
she thought she could smell the sharp
tang of copper inside the car
blood they tumbled down and down forever
and then just as her consciousness was
fading there was a jolt and a thick
splash sally's eyes shot open
her entire body howled with agony she
looked out her window
it was dark and the headlights had
evidently gone out but she could see
that the car had come to a stop
thankfully upright but sinking quickly
into the black morass of the lake
realizing she had no idea how deep the
water was sally immediately began
cranking the window down
murmuring thanks to various deities that
this car didn't have power windows
she tugged at thomas's arm and heard him
groan it was the most beautiful sound in
the world
tom he opened his eyes groggily she saw
a trickle of blood on his face
he had broken his nose tom listen
she could feel the car being sucked
under and tried to stifle her panic
the window was down they would get out
we're in the lake
she told him his eyes registered a dim
comprehension
i'm going out then i can drag you i
don't think we're far from shore okay
he stared at her die he said she glanced
into the driver's seat
dye was slumped forward over the wheel
not moving
forget it he's dead she said not knowing
that for sure but past caring at this
point
dye was the one to blame for this after
all come on we're going
the lake had swallowed the tires and was
now working its hungry way up the doors
inch by steady inch
sally squeezed out the open window and
stumbled face first into the black water
which was horribly slimy and smelled
putrid sputtering and gagging she came
to the surface relieved to see that
thomas had managed to get most of the
way out of the window on his own
she grabbed his arm with her one good
one and pulled him the rest of the way
out
her broken bone shrieking like an alarm
bell in her head
the water finally reached the open
window and began pouring in
cascades of filthy stinking brown
coating the upholstery
sally swam a little through the muck
dragging thomas behind her
trying to get them clear of the suction
as the car was pulled under
for a second she paused wanting to turn
back and try to get die out
but then with a great bubbling crash the
car tipped forward
and seemed to go down all at once as
though the mud beneath had reached up to
claim its sacrifice
sally cried out sucking in some of the
water inadvertently and then hacking it
back up the thought of dye still alive
in there waking up for a second only to
realize what was happening
it was too horrible to think about no he
was dead she told herself
thomas bobbed in the water next to her
dazed but conscious
jesus he breathed he was already dead
there was nothing i could do
she paddled toward the shore which was
farther away than she had anticipated
images of dye opening his eyes and that
dark stinking water kept trying to crowd
her thoughts but she forced them away
are you all right thomas splashed after
her half swimming half sinking his face
a grimace
my nose hurts and my legs are you okay i
think my arm's broken but other than
that yeah
she strove grimly toward the damn shore
she realized they were pretty far from
the nearest village but she didn't care
as long as she was out of this
disgusting lake she didn't care if they
had to walk to timbuktu
at least they were alive her whole body
one terrible ache she finally crawled up
onto the grass
panting and puking up the slimy water
thomas followed a moment later
she lay there next to him for what
seemed like hours looking up at the
sliver of moon hovering in the basin of
sky above them
the lake water on her skin felt oily and
diseased the thickness of it coating the
insides of her nose and mouth
it almost seemed alive crawling she
turned her head to throw up again
at last they gathered enough energy to
stagger to their feet and begin the long
climb up the slope
sally looked back but the car was gone
the only hint of disturbance was the
intermittent pop of brown bubbles on the
otherwise placid surface
clouds scuttered across the moon
temporarily plunging them into an almost
complete darkness
sally looked up thinking she could
barely see a few lights here and there
shining like beacons from the farm
scattered around the mountains
the thought of a warm house a cup of hot
tea a soft chair in front of the fire
and a telephone quickened her pace the
clouds passed and the sliver of moon
shone down again and the figures were
all around them
they ringed the lake standing at the
apex of the slope staring down with eyes
like holes
they were white and very thin their
clothes were rags
their faces were like skull faces sally
stopped and gaped up at them
she felt thomas's hand grip hers tightly
and she squeezed back
but she wasn't afraid not of them she
was calm
there were so many more of them than
there were headstones they stood
shoulder to shoulder men and women and
children
an unbroken circle all around the lake
sally wondered what their names had been
wondered if they were sad that the world
had forgotten them
they didn't move and she didn't move but
she felt the oily water on her skin
felt its seething bacteria entering her
body breaching its defenses
for a moment she thought fondly of dye
and how he had been the lucky one after
all
she glanced over at thomas his face was
very pale in the dim moonlight
as if you were already dead she knew
that he could see them too
that he knew why they were there she
squeezed his hand again
at least they were still together they
walked up the slope hand in hand
sally and thomas the quarantined the
diseased the infectious
their limbs were heavy with lake water
and pathogens the ring of ghosts parted
for them as they crested the slope and
took their places among the dead
you